اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا نحيكم
الى بانوراما نناقش فيها كالعاده ابرز
ملفات اليوم وفي ملفاتي هذا المساء رغم
تفوق الجمهوري لماذا كانت نتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه مخيبه للامل بالنسبه
لفريق ترامب وهزيمه بطعم الفوز يقول البعض
بنسبه لفريق وهل تقلب تلك نتائج خطه
الغريمين فترشح لرئاسه مستقبلا وهل سيكون
احدهما الرئيس القادم ام ربما شخص ثالث
وفي الموضوع الثاني الانسحاب الروسي من
خرسان انتصارون اوكراني ام منوره من موسكو
تثير شوكولاس
[موسيقى]
يترقبوا الامريكيون نتائج نهائيات
الانتخابات من نصفيه بينما يمر كل الحزبين
بحاله من الاحباط فالجمهوريون توقعوا فوزا
اكبر من ذلك
والديمقراطيون يتجهزون لخساره مجلس النواب
رئيس الامريكي
للصحافيين في البيت الابيض على نيته
الترشح لولايه الثانيه عام 2024
متعهدا بالتواصل الى قرار النهائيين في
هذا الصد رد مطلع العام المقبل كما استغل
بايدينا فرصه ثانيه للمعارضه الجمهوريه
مؤكدا انفتاحه على جميع الافكار الجيده
كما قال هذا هو تتركز الانظار من الان على
انتخابات 24 ومن قبلها على حمله
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب الذي كان يراهن على
تحقيق وممثلي الحزب فوزا كبيرا اقر بان
نتائج انتخابات منتصف الولايه كانت مخيبه
للامال نوعا ما لكنه اضاف عبر منصته
الاعلاميه تروس سوشيال وقال من وجهه نظر
الخاصه كان الانتصار كبيرا للغايه ويتحدث
عن اعلان كبير جدا ومنتظر في الخامس عشر
من نوفمبر
ار ار سامسونج
كيف كيف
[موسيقى]
دكتور وليد
اولا انا من المراقبين الذين لا يوافقون
على هذه الفكره العاطفيه انه هذه موجه
حمراء وهذه موجه زرقاء هذه الالتين
الاعلامتين للمعسكرين هي التي تقول بهذه
الافكار لتعبئه القواعد ان هذه الموجه
الحمراء سوف تاتي فيتحمس جزءا منهم
الحقيقه هي امران الامر الاول هو قوه
الاله التنظيميه على الارض لكلال حزبان
هذا واحد اثنين من هو في الحكم ومن هو
خارج الحكم وهنالك نقطه ثالثه هنا بالطبعه
هو ايداء الاداره يعني اداء الاداره هو
الذي يخلق الموجات الى هنالك مما استخلص
به هنا انه ما حصل عليه الجمهوريون وخاصه
قاعده رئيس سابق ترامب هو كبير يعني ان
يحصل على مجلس النواب
ويتمكن الان السيطره عليها في بدايه العام
المقبل هو شيء كبير الان الزعماء عليهم ان
يكيفوا كما سمعنا الرئيس السابق ترامب انه
حتى ولو حصلنا على ذلك فهذا
عظيم وانا المسؤول عن هذا الانتصار هذا
كلام سياسي الواقع هو ارقام على الارض
دكتور ادمان هذه التعبئه كما اا كنا نتحدث
عنها وحتى تكرار همم فكره الموجه الحمراء
التي ستشتاخذ الانتخابات والتي سيفوز على
اثرها الجمهوريون بفارق عريض حتى
الديمقراطيون صدقوها كذلك وتصريحات بيضا
ابلغ دليل على ذلك لانه اعتبر خسارته فوزا
او على الاقل بانه خسر همم باقل الاضرار
كيف يفسر او بما يفسر ذلك
اولا يجب ان ننظر الى ان الاداء الاداره
واداء الرئيس بعد ان كان هو احد القضايا
الرئيسيه التي نظر اليها الكثير من
الناخبين الامريكيين الى حد كبير في هذه
كانت استفتاء على اداء الاداره ولكنها لم
تكن هذه القضيه الوحيده من ما ساعد الكثير
من المحللين
المؤسسات التي تقوم باستطلاع الرايه على
الاعتقاد بانه ستكون هناك موجه حمراء كانت
هناك عند القضايا التضخم المالي موضوع
الاقتصاد الذي هو عاده القضيه الاساسيه
بالنسبه للمواطن الامريكي ولغاليبيه
الامريكيه لان هذه هي القضيه الاولى ما لم
تكن هناك حرب ثانيا همم ثالثا بالاحرام
موضوع الجريمه زياد الجريمه واعمال العنف
في الولايات المتحده موضوع همم الغياب
الامن الحدود على جنوب في جنوب الولايات
المتحده همم كل هذه القضايا كانت لصالح
الجمهوريين ولكن في نفس الوقت كان هناك
ايضا قضايا لصالح الديمقراطيه اولا
جمهوريين لم ينفقوا الاموال مثلا وهناك
انتقالات لرئيس مجلس الشيوخ مثل مكانه
لانه لم ينفق اموال ويدعم بعض المرشحين
ربما لان بعضهم يدعمهم ترامب وبعضهم غير
لم يكن هو مرتاح عندهم
لقدراتهم وبالتالي هناك ايضا قسم انقسام
داخل الحزب الجمهوري كما هناك انقسام داخل
الحزب الحزين
وقلت بانه هناك كميه قضايا تخدم مصلحه
الجمهوريه ورغم ذلك لم يفوز الجمهوريون
كيفيه التي يتوقعها البال طرح سؤال حضور
ترامب هل تعتقد بان حضور ترامب تصريحات
ترامب التي سبقت هذه الانتخابات وحتى دعمه
لبعض المتسابقين على منصب الحكام او حتى
على ما نصب اخرى اضرت تعتقد بالحزن
ولكن بدون شاكر في بعض بالنسبه لبعض
المرشحين دعم ترامب لمرشحين معين اثارت
اسئله حول كفاءته الى المرشحين من بين
الذين اثارهم اسئله كان زعيم الاقل هي
الجمهوريه في مجلس الشيوخ وعدد اخر من
قاده الحزب الجمهوري الذين لا يحبوا ترامب
ولا يثق به ويريدون اذا قادروا اذا حته من
الساحه ولكنه دعم حوالي 330 مرشحا همم
خلال الحملات الانتخابيه التمهيديه
والانتخابات الاخيره وحقق انتصارات اكثر
من ملاحقه به وبلاشخاص الذين اختارهم
خزائهم ولكن هذه واحده غير كان هناك ما
نعلم جميعا هناك انقسام حاد في المجتمع
الامريكي هناك كمان همم يكره ترامب وهنا
كمان يحب ترامب داخل الحزب الجمهوري
وخارجه طبعا
داخل الحزب الجمهوري دكتور رائد دكتور
فارس همم هل تتفق مع ضيفي بان صوره ترامب
الحاضره بتصريحاته
المشاغبه يقول البعض لم تؤثر بتاتا بل
ساعدت الحزب او كما يقول جانب اخر في
المقابل بان الرجل اضر بالحزب الرجل احدث
انقسام وشرخ عميق داخل الحزب وربما هذا
الفوز الظهيل يتحمل كذلك هو مسؤوليته ليس
الفوز اتحدث عن الضان يتحمل مسؤوليه
في تحليلي اعتقد بعض الخبره والسنوات ان
عندما يوصف رجل سياسي ترامب في هذه الحاله
بانه هو الذي دعم وهو الذي عبا و بسببه
تمت هذه الخسائر هذا الطرف الاخر اكان هذا
الطرف الديمقراطي لتخفيف من معنويات خصامه
او داخل حزن كما تفضلتم بالنقاش الان
هنالك جناح كامل على الصعيد المسؤولين
وليس على الصعيد القاعده الشعبيه الذي
يعارض ترامب وبالتالي يقول للحزب وقواعده
انه ترامب اخذنا الى الكارثه كان بامكاننا
ان نصنع موجه حمراء ولم تحصل بسببه بسبب
كلام الى الى اخره اعتقادي انه قوه ترامب
عمليا بغض النظر عن نقاط ضعفه هو النقاب
ضعفه معروفه كلامه عندما يتكلم الاشخاص
هذا كل ضعف ولكن
على ماده عامه كامل ان يتكلم ببساطه
بالقواعد الشعبيه وكما قال الدكتور
وعد الشعبيه اصلا مستاءه من اداء همم هذه
الاداره للاسباب ايضا التي ذكرت اذا من هو
هذا الزعيم الصوت الذي بامكانه ان ياتي
ويعبئ هذه القواعد الشعبيه كانت ترامب
يعني اا كان احبوها او لم يحبوها هذه همم
هذه هي قدرته على التعبئه الان هذه
الاكثريه التي اتت انا لم اكن اتصور على
الصعيد تحليل الشخصي انه الجمهوريون سوف
ياخذون همم يعني فارق بستين 60 مقعد هذا
مستحيل بين خمسه سبعه وهو قليل 27 25 كما
يبدو الارقام تدل الان هذا منطقي ان يكون
لهم هذه
الاثريه في مجلس الشيوخ الخريطه مختلفه
كليا انتخاب السنه مختلف كليا عن
الانتخابات اعضاء الكونجرس الايام
الاسابيع المقبله مع من سوف تكون بشكل
حاسه الاثريه في السنه الدكتور
هذه الارقام حواليه او هذه النسبه الاوليه
انتظرنا تصريحات كل من بيض وترامب
وانتظرنا اعلان ترشح للرئاسيه هذا كان
منتظر حتى الاجواء بالداخل الاجواء
القريبه اتحدث من الرجلين تقول بانه قد
يتم الاعلان عن ترشح باين تحدث عنيجا في
انتظار نهايه السنه وترامب لم يتحدث بتاتا
عن حتى نيته الترشح هل تعتقد بانه بعد هذه
النتائج هناك شيء داخل الاحزاب هناك
تغيرات على مستوى الاحزاب قد تحدث
بدون شكانه هناك تحديات كبيره داخل
الحزبين هناك من يتحدى كل من
القيادتين
وقياده الرئيس السابق
ولكن ترامب لانه سيعلن قريبا خبر مهم جدا
واعتقد انه ربما
سيرشح في هذه في هذا القطار الذي سيجري به
من خلال
ايضا قد قال بانه يتوقع انه سيرشح نفسه
للانتخابات ولكن المشكله بالنسبه لترامب
لديه مشكلاته مثلا هو الان قد يواجه
منافسه من الحاكم ولايه فلوريدا الذي يحضر
بشعبيه واسعه وحقاقا انتصارات كبيره
وحذاره ترامب سانتوس هو حاكم ولايه
فلوريدا وكما يواجه ايضا الانتقادات الحزب
ولكن ترامب هو الذي لديه قاعده شعبيه قويه
لديه دعم حوالي 70%
الجمهوريه بالنسبه للرئيس ترامب هو ايضا
عبء الى حد ما على الديمقراطيسي وعلى قناه
ديموقراطيين يواجهوا مشكله كبيره همم اذا
همم ازاحه ترامب همم فمن سيكون الرئيس هل
هم لا يريدون كامله هذا الرئيس نسبه كبيره
من القيادات الديمقراطيه لا تريد ان تكون
كامله هايرس هي الرئيس في الولايات
المتحده وبالتالي فان هناك تحديات كبيره
تواجهه الحزبين وهذين القائدتين لديهم
طموحات كبيره ويا مليان بان يستمر ولكن
هناك تحديات كبيره امامهما خاصه امام امام
الرئيس لانه يعاني من مشاكل اخرى بالاضافه
الى الصراعات الداخليه داخل الحزمه ههه
بان همم الايام القادمه ستكون حبلها
بالمفاجات وربما سنكون امام اعلانات رسميه
عن ترشحات رئاسه رغم ان كما قال دكتور
ادماند قد يكون او قد تمثل الحب على حسب
وترامب قد يكون هو المسؤول عن هذا
الانقسام داخل حزب الجمهوريين رغم قاعدته
الشعبيه الكبيره
ونعرف بعض المحيطين به يعني في اذا لاحظنا
بالمهرجانات الماضيه لسته اشهر الماضيه
ماذا كان يقول انا عندي خبر جيد جدا
ساشارك بهذا الخبر معكم في مرحله المال
جميعا 90% من الناس الموجودين يفهمون انه
سيتكلم عن ترشيحه وكان يعني هو عندما قال
قبل الانتخابات ليله قبل الانتخابات انها
عنده خبر مهم اظن الناس وقتت الكاميرا
واثت همم يعني اتمثلوا الاعلان ظن انه سوف
يعلن والان قال انه لا سوف يعلن الخبر
المهم جدا في منتصف هذا الشهر
يريد ان يستمر الضغط انه المرشح لانه يدرس
ردات فعل خاصه الذين انتخبوا يريد اصواتهم
ان تكون معهم اما بالنسبه يعني ربما تظهر
الامور وكانه حربا اهليه داخل حزب
الجمهوري سوف تقسموا سوف
ترامب لا اعتقد هذا هو الواقع الواقع انه
هو كان نجم الساطع يعني يخرج الى القمه
تقريبا ولكن ديسانتسي يعرف انه ليس لدي
على الصعيد الوطني هذه الجماهير التي يؤثر
عليها همم ترامب وديسانتسي يبدو انه يريد
اما ان يكون مرشحا جديا بعد اربع سنوات
اما يعني باقصى الاحوال ان يكون مرشحا
للنيابه الرئيس وهو لا يحب هذا الموقع
لانه قد يحصره هو كحاكم
اكثر سياسيا وبالنسبه للنفوذ احيانا يقوم
بهذه التصريحات ضد سانتوس ليمكن نفسك
فبامك انا اقول انه المحيطين بالتراب انتم
الى الرئيس السابق وقال له انت لي حاشا ان
تنتقد سانتوس بالعكس اندحه فهو اما ان
يكون داعما لك كحاكم قوي اما ان يعني
تختاره كنائب للرئيس مرشح بناء بالرئيس
اذا صحيح في الاعلام هنالك
وكانه انقلب عليه في الفتره من الفترات
وترامب لن ينسى مثل هكذا همم ردات فعل
يتذكرها وسيبتها
كما اعرف الترام ربما قد تغير هو دائما
يكون له مسافه من اي مرشح الا نذكر في
العام 2016 عندما كان هنالك مرشحين
جمهوريه اخرين نصفهم اصبحوا في وزارته في
حكومته كان ينتقدهم وكان ينتقد ماركو
الصغير وينتقد هذا وهذا وبعد ذلك عندما
انتصر عندما انتصر جماعهم واخذ ثلثين
ثلثينهم معه في الحكومه انا باعتقادي
عندما تقترب الامور في يعني موضوع اعلان
ترامب سوف يرشح نفسه ويصلح مجالا نائب كيس
وبعتقاد الديس سانتوس هو الذي لن يتخطى
الخط الحمراء مع ترامب لانه فاهم شخصيه
ترامبو بالتالي هو يريد ان يمكن موقعه في
الفلور ده قبل ان يتخذ قرار اخر
شديد بيضا حدثني عن النقطه الاولى وهي
ترامب
كبير بهذا الموضوع بسرعه
على زميل سريع القيادات المقرره في الحزب
غير متحمسه له وخائفه من ان يترشح وخائف
من ان يصطدم بالمرشح الجمهور طبعا كما قال
ايضا همم نائبه الرئيس ليست ايضا الخيار
الاول عندهم خيارات ممتازه برايهم ولكن
المشكله الان في عمليه التغيير كيف يغيرهم
هو لم يقبل ايضا يريد ان يكون المرشح هذا
سوف يهز وحده الحزب الديمقراطي الشباب
عمليا ليس متحمسين لبعض يريدون شخصيه
اثريه اكثر حاسبه عندهم مشكله عليهم ان
يحلوها كيف يحلوها
الدكتور عدنان
في في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهو شكل
خاص في الواقعه من تشكيلات السياسيه ولكن
البعض كذلك في المقابله يتحدث عن اننا
فعليا عمليا امام اربعه احزاب كل حزب
الديمقراطي او جمهوريه يتضمن جزءا منفصلين
غير متوافقين على عده نقاط
اليوم كان ان يضر ذلك بالحزبين الكبيرين
وهل يمكن ان ينتج ذلك لشكل جديد ربما في
الفترات القادمه تعتقد
من تيار داخل كل من الحسبان الرئيسيين
ولكن في نفس الوقت الكثير يعتمد على من هو
القائد من هو زعيم الحزب هناك شخصيات قويه
شخصيات كاريز مائيه احيانا لديها قدرات
مثلا في التاريخيه راينا همم الرئيس كندي
راعي حتى الرئيس جونسون
كان لديه شعبيه
ولكن الان فعلا الرئيس بعد ان يواجه
تحديات كبيره وهناك معارضه له في الحزب
ولكن ليس طائره تماما وخاصه قبل
الانتخابات ومن هنا تاتي اهميه هذه
الاقتصامات ولكن بالاضافه الى هذين هذه
الابتسامات هناك ايضا تيار اخر وهو تيار
المستقلين وهذا التيار ليست تيارا واعتقد
انه هو لاعب دورا في النتائج التي
شاهدناها في الانتخابات الاخيره لان هذا
الحزب بينما صوت البعض همم لاشخاص معينين
على المستوى الفقرالي صوتوا لي سيارات
وشخصيات من الحزب الاخر على المستوى
المحلي وبالتالي المستقلين لاعيب دورا
مهما واساسيا مع انهم غير منظمين ولكن لا
هؤلاء ربما ما يجمعهم انهم لا ياتقوا
بالحزبين ولا يعتقدوا بان واشنطن همم
والكونجرس يمثلهم الان ولذلك لديهم
مواقفهم والديهم همم رؤى مختلفه عن تلك
التي يتبناها كل من الحزب الجمهوري
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لن يكون لهم تاثير
الكبير خاصه اننا سنكون امام شخصيتين
واحده مرشحه من الحزب الجمهوري والثانيه
من الحزب الديمقراطي فتاثيرهم سيكون همم
اقل دكتور صحيح
حتى في الانتخابات الرئاسه سيكون مؤثرين
ولكن سيكون مؤثرين خاصه
كان هناك تقارب بين الرئيس المرشحين
الجمهوري همم
والديمقراطيه عند اذن سيكون المستقلون هم
الذين سيقرروا المستقبل الرئيس الامريكي
من هو سيكون الرئيس
في الواقع لترامب قاله بعد الاعلان عن هذه
النتائج قال بان من فازوا انا المسؤول عن
فوزهم او على الاقل يعود لي همم
يعني مسؤوليه فوزي ولكن من خسروا فهم
يتحمل وحدهم المسؤوليه طيب ما الذي يريده
ترامب من مثل هكذا تصريحات خاصه وانها
تصريحات مستفزه هذا كما نقرا نحن الا اذا
كانت هذه التصريحات تجد من يحبها
ويستصيغها بداخل الامريكي
القاعده الشعبيه للرئيس ترامب اساسا كما
لاحظنا لا تحب هكذا تصريحات ولكن الخيار
الحالي الوحيد لها هو ترامب وهذه يعني هذه
قصه الرئيس ترامب منذ سنوات حتى عندما
انتقد سكانها بعض الاشخاص في الحضور يعني
لم يكن مرتاحين ولكن ما هو التيار الاخر
هو ترامب بالنسبه لهم وبالتالي عندما قال
اولا ان هو لاعب دورا كبيرا لو لو قالها
بهذه الطريقه لكان كل الناس ايدون وعندما
قال انا لن اكون مسؤول انا لن اكون مسؤولا
اذا لم ينجحوا هذا امر القاعده لا تريده
ولكن لا تعارضه الى قال اهو
التصريحات لنفهم كيف سيكون الوضع شكرا لكم
الدكتور وليد فارس الخبير في السياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه ومن واشنطن كذلك
الدكتور غريب الاستاذ في العلاقه الدوليه
شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]